it's easy to become nominal media bias
these days so the ingram angle's keeping
track of the worst
offenders every week now joining me is
adam gullett who's the president
of accuracy in media adam great to see
you now let's begin with cnn's don lemon
you guys are good friends
and he was claiming to know the real
reason
that the white house wasn't holding
their daily coveted press briefings
actually pay attention to what's
happening in washington with this
administration
not having the briefings pretending that
this is
over because they want to move on to
other things so
not having those briefings that's all
part of the plan
for you to think that this is over
first cnn complained that the didn't
they complain the briefings were a waste
of time they cut away they hardly ever
showed them and then
lemon specifically said they shouldn't
even be taken as live events so now
why is he whining at him
it's unbelievable if cognitive
dissonance is holding
two opposing viewpoints at the same time
what is the term for holding two
opposing viewpoints the same week
they're for the briefings they're
against the briefings they're for the
briefings
literally whatever position trump takes
they immediately write their copy
we're against it now it's it's so
goofy i mean it's like there's no other
issue happening in the entire world
it's important but there are other
issues they have to get to it's it's
crazy
but they want us to stay in this
perpetual panic mode because they think
that
you know is it's maybe good for their
ratings or maybe it's bad for trump
i don't know what their full uh analysis
is all right
next up a new york magazine reporter
adam doesn't understand the difference
between
losing people in a war versus a pandemic
if an american president loses more
americans over the course of six weeks
and died in the entirety of the vietnam
war does he deserve to be reelected
adam a lot of folks made this comparison
this week
la times had a headline and we've had
really bad
flu seasons that have had you know
almost that
amount of deaths as well this year was a
bad flu season we don't even have those
full numbers
you know your thoughts on this yeah it's
unbelievable
you know first they wanted to make this
trump's katrina
now they're trying to make it trump's
vietnam any minute they're going to
start putting the counter
in the bottom corner of the screen with
the deaths each day uh rachel maddow is
going to start telling people the
pandemic
is now unwinnable in distributing
cyanide tablets for her viewers to put
in their kombucha
their overstatement of this is
outrageous
now finally here's obama's former
campaign manager
trying to rewrite history there's a real
difference between the media looking
into these
allegations which is what they have done
to tara reid and
what they did to brett kavanaugh and and
mitch mcconnell
who you know got that process over as
fast as he could get it over to protect
the nominee for supreme court
adam you're gonna you notice you got no
pushback for that absurd claim
yeah no they they have the intellectual
integrity of the cast or they lack the
intellectual integrity
of the cast of uh with rose mcgowan in
them
it's unbelievable that we're getting
better leadership from milano
adam great to see you have a great
weekend